he might see himself working a job under
a tyrant because he works unto
God and part of his calling since he was
zero years old is to have a miserable
life on behalf of something bigger than
himself so that everybody else can
worship
right wow uhhuh and
so there's a different thing if you sit
down and go your job is killing you yada
y that's different then
um I love you and I can't tell you when
I just think about your life how proud I
am of you that you've given up every
Sunday for your entire life to serve
other people so they can have an an
experience of meeting God and I don't
want you to Die
Young I don't want you to have a heart
attack I want you to walk in this house
and be so happy and joyful to walk in
here can we create that world